all right
[Music]
it's unfortunate we have to call some
Haitians enemies but the Haitian
oligarchs and politicians give them guns
and ammunition to destroy our
communities
yesterday
[Music]
there's a difference between a gang and
an armed group we have an ideology we
have a vision to see Haiti with all the
services with drinkable water Schools
jobs and with security
thank you
[Music]
the PM's not asking for foreign troops
to come to the country they want foreign
forces to protect them from the crimes
they have committed several times the
un's intervened in Haiti and that the
result is always zero
[Laughter]
[Music]
foreign